foreign
[Music]
hi there and welcome to the next video
on contrast and I kind of went back and
forth on what I was going to show you
guys in this example uh but I wanted
when I ended up landing on was what you
see right here
um it's this uh skull the cow skull
contrasted black on white uh I thought
about showing you a couple other things
but ultimately came back to this one
because I wanted to keep it simple for
this week like I've you know I want to
just to show you like the style frames I
don't want to show you a motion this
week I've been focused just on the
design side the the you know the single
image and uh in future weeks we will get
more uh we will go back into contrast
for sure in fact there's contrast stuff
coming up very soon uh that's definitely
more involved
um but for this example
I just want to show you how I created uh
this contrasting uh style frame that you
know it's very simple but it's pretty
cool at the same time there's some
interesting things going on uh in this
image there's some
interesting texture in here
um there's these checkerboard patterns
back here there's some grit some Grime
going on
um and then you know obviously the black
and white so a lot of times as we saw in
the examples
um black and white contrast is very
popular
um and you see it all the time you see
it where there's black versus white or
shifted this way or diagonal you know
whatever so I tried to kind of stay in
that realm for this example
um and I came up with this so
um let me show you how I did this
um fairly quickly
okay so we're gonna jump back in to the
project and we're going to make a new
composition
and I made this 1080 by 1080 again
because I designed this for Instagram
because it's going to go up on the
Instagram page uh frames per second
doesn't matter but 1080 by 1080 and
we'll call this skull
O2
first I'm going to do is I'm going to
drag in my skull
layer which
is right here it's called cow
and I'll scale it down
something like
so whoops
guys have the right tool selected there
I have the mask tool so there's our
school
um you know we could make it larger
you know there's different ways you
could frame this and we are going to
talk about framing in future lessons so
as we move through these lessons
throughout the year things will
definitely get a little bit more
involved as I can show you more more
aspects together elements and principles
in one single project but for now I'm
trying to keep it fairly straightforward
and just focused on what we're learning
and building upon what we've already
learned so
it's definitely a challenge for me but
it's fun at the same time
so anyways let's
something like so
after we have the cow and a the cow
skull in a good position I'm going to go
back to my project I'm going to select
the paper I used and this is just a
piece of torn paper
that I brought into PNG with an alpha
Channel as you can see here and I am
going to start
creating some contrast with this paper
the reason I'm actually designing inside
of After Effects versus Photoshop
is for one main reason for me which is I
have so many different plugins
third-party plugins inside of after
effects that once I get a good design
base where I like it to be I can easily
apply
different effects that I see necessary
for that design right here in After
Effects in the past I've had to design a
base in Photoshop
bring that base file into After Effects
break it into layers and then start
applying my effects and years and years
ago I've you know just thought well why
don't I just do this all in After
Effects why do I have to design in
Photoshop and so I moved it over to to
After Effects you know for ninety
percent of the time now there are
certain times when
you know I have to be in Photoshop to
cut out images
um if it's very detailed cutting out you
know simple cutouts I can use masks and
after effects great but things like hair
or just certain things where I cut out
ice you know start in Photoshop bring
that in to After Effects and there's
also a couple other plugins I do have in
Photoshop that are not available in
After Effects which I wish they were but
they're not unfortunately so but anyways
90 of the time I'm in After Effects
designing so even if it's a still image
Okay so we've got the paper here and I'm
just going to rotate it
90 degrees
and I am going to tell the cow to Alpha
mat the paper and there you go there's
the first part of our contrast the one
thing I immediately see is I don't love
how big this tear is right this tear of
paper if I turn the paper back on you
can see that now maybe it works for your
example but for your design but I'm just
going to scale this down I want smaller
I'll turn it back off
you know maybe something
maybe even more thirty percent let's see
what this looks like
yeah I like that
so that's the first
part of our design right so um you'll
notice or you probably noticed that it
was black and white so I'm just going to
go to effect color correction tent
and it's black and white right so now
I'm going to select paper cow hit
command D on the keyboard to duplicate
on this cow I'm going to affle out
excuse me I'm going to Alpha invert the
mat so the bottom one was Alpha matte
top one is Alpha invert matte and
there's our other half of the image
right this one has the tent applied on
reverse it so I just hit swap swap
colors
and there you go so actually this is the
reverse of the other image I did uh but
that's okay actually we'll go ahead and
just
swap the bottom one so that's closer to
what I originally had
um so looking at this now I don't like
this section right here with the tears
I'm going to select both pieces of paper
and just I don't know maybe something
like that rotate
oh something I guess that's still 90
degrees
actually gonna drag them up
we're down
okay it works for me
cool so next I'm going to do is hmm
let's bring in the digital texture that
I used which is this
is not that one it is
this puppy
so I uh came up with a search term a
while back which was zepto bars right
here I don't remember how I came up with
this word I've never heard of a zepto
bar before but I Googled it and under
reuse for modification larger than four
megapixels I found several images I
liked this was one this is the one that
you saw here in After Effects
um but uh just really cool zepto bars
something inside of a computer so really
cool
I think this one's super cool as well
um I'm gonna do some more work with
these in the near future I've already
started a few other projects with them
that I'll show you in the future so
so I'm going to turn this guy on I'm
going to scale him down
and just find something interesting
I don't know maybe
maybe that's good where it's at and I'm
gonna duplicate the cow
and
yeah that's really cool
and I found that using the Divide
transfer mode was pretty cool
after I made it black and white
now what I love about this version I'm
creating is that there's most of the
textures over here there's a little bit
over in here which is pretty cool
I'm also going to turn the transparency
down to 50 percent
and I'm going to go ahead and drop in a
new solid background but we'll call it
checkerboard
bring that down there and to this layer
I'm going to apply I believe it's
generate checkerboard yeah
laughs and all I did on this was I
scaled it way up
I originally started with this with the
four squares
but for whatever reason it was really
bugging me so right so right now this is
bugging me so I'm going to turn that off
um
all I do is I rotated
45 degrees
and I believe I scale it up yeah
you know there's all different ways you
could play around with this
um that's kind of cool like that
turn that guy back on
and I'm going to play around with the
levels here just a bit color correction
levels
so I like how it's looking but it's just
there's something it's too
it's too contrasty I think
which this is going to make it more
contrasty which I don't want
that's not too bad though like that
that's kind of interesting I actually
kind of like that
um let's play around a little bit more
here with the texture
I like that and then I used uh grime
which is a texture pack I'm going to be
giving to you guys again
last time we got grunge this I'm going
to get grime
and we're going to put this on
multiply I think
oh maybe up here towards the top and
what's cool this is a quick time file
but I can just move through and find a
section of it I like which
a little too much
I actually don't mind that
um and then I had another texture that I
brought in which is like this kind of
stamped
uh feel to it and for this guy
I set him to Overlay now let's try
you see how it really this texture alone
is totally affecting you know the dark
side of the skull and it completely
changes the look depending on what
transfer mode I'm in so what I'm doing
is I'm hitting shift minus or shift Plus
on my Mac keyboard and it's cycling
through you'll see it down here
cycling through
and then a lot of times what I'll do is
I'll just drag
you know through the timeline just I'll
move elements up and down the timeline
just to see
if it affects things so that's with it
more towards the top off on
[Music]
above Grime it doesn't work
go back to multiply
overlay most of the time it's multiply
overlay or screen those are the three
that I always start with because they
give me the most
um you know different they give they
give me more uh variations and then
based upon if I like like overlay then
I'll try some of those
transfer modes right there that are
categorized with overlay like soft light
hard light linear if I like multiply
I'll try darken color burn those kind of
things so those are the three I usually
start with
I'm also going to add a new uh
solid for the background and make it
just black
it should darken up
these checkerboards yeah so this is
without
and this is width
so let's do this
[Music]
foreign
so that's fairly interesting
[Music]
something I also want to do is I want to
scale down
the grime I'm actually going to rotate
it 90 degrees
that's pretty cool
the one thing that's bugging me right
now is I'm just staring at this is the
texture the digital texture right here
and I think it's just because that image
isn't working for me anymore
so all I did here was just rotate the
texture just to see
I was looking there
let's go back to 100 opacity
and start a screen no
multiply no
maybe difference
no
so I'll cycle through them
again
[Music]
so that's uh really interesting to me
but obviously
it uh
covers everything up that we've already
done
so I could try and do is drag that all
below the original cow image
and just make that cow image a transfer
mode of
so yeah it's already interesting overlay
screen
multiply so control Z control Z
that's pretty cool
the paper is too far to the right
so I selected both layers I'm nudging
them over with my keys right now
and I am going to
readjust the texture again
yeah that's really cool actually I like
that it looks like it's got like this
kind of that digital static feel to the
left side and a very organic feel to the
right side
so that's what I want to show you today
there's no chromatic aberration there's
no
um
special
plugins although we could do something
interesting just really quickly you know
how much I love the lighting effect I
love to use glow
let's see if so if I turn down the
threshold
we could try that
that's actually really cool
that's what the overall brightness
you know with this glow there's so many
things you could do with you know like
the width
Crank that slightly
um you know the side width
which I don't like that with y
a it's okay
maybe somewhere in there and then just
adjusting the um widths of the red
greens and blues would really make a
huge difference you see there's purplish
colors coming on this is making
everything more green as I Crank It Up
I mess with the Reds
that's kind of interesting
I still like it more black and white but
with glow without with glow without
something one more thing I'll try as
well is a lot of times if I have a lot
of black in a design
I'll actually try uh lighting glow darks
and what that does is it brings in this
this extra Darkness I don't really know
how to explain it
um you know the factual reason for what
it's doing
[Music]
um but with without with without you can
see that it just makes the blacks that
much blacker but it gives it like this
black glow as you can see in here so you
can adjust the darkness
the threshold again
but I don't like it on this particular
version I do like the glow like I
typically always do we could try maybe a
little bit of a red glue just to see
it's not gonna
knock it off the Green's kind of
interesting
I really like how it's highlighting this
side of the skull
more than that side
so that's kind of cool it's just a
little bit of a pinkish off-white
color and I'll crank up the brightness
just a tad there
we go there is our contrasted skull
um looks really cool to me I'm gonna
post this on Instagram uh leave me a
comment let you know let me know what
you thought of this week's material on
contrast your feedback is very important
to me so I know what to do for future
lessons how to keep rolling with it you
know some of these lessons are more
simple some are more advanced so I could
try and mix it up for all of you guys so
until uh next week I'm Cameron and this
is stylecraft see ya